Порожні готелі та безлюдні лижні траси.
На дорогах - коронавірусні блок-пости.
Популярні гірські курорти в Івано-Франківській області, яка місяць тому потрапила у червону зону карантину, нині нагадують міста-привиди.
Єдине, що на Прикарпатті працює на повну потужність - це ковідні лікарні.
Кисень не пропадав цілу ніч? Не пропадав.
Приходиш зранку - вони одразу кажуть, якщо не було кисню.
Тоді користуємося концентраторами. Виходимо, як можемо.
Галина Мацюк - одна з двох інфекціоністок у Яремчанській лікарні.
За її словами, хворих на ковід клініка почала приймати лише восени минулого року.
Відтоді в інфекціоністів перекваліфікувалися і невропатологи, і терапевти.
А оскільки ліжок в інфекційних боксах бракувало, для пацієнтів з коронавірусом переобладнали терапевтичне відділення.
Нині у лікарні - 70 ковідних місць. Зазвичай всі вони зайняті.
На сьогоднішній день було два вільних ліжка. Причому це чоловічі місця і це ліжка без кисню.
Але зараз вони автоматично заповняться. Практично у нас такого не буває, щоб було вільне ліжко.
Якщо з'являється вільне ліжко, то нам екстрено привозять пацієнтів із сусідніх районів - випадки, які потребують госпіталізації.
Більшість пацієнтів - залежні від кисню. Його в Яремчанську лікарню привозять і з Івано-Франківська, і з Чернівців.
Лише у лютому на забезпечення хворих на ковід киснем лікарня витратила понад 300 тисяч гривень.
І хоча страх залишитися без кисню переслідує і лікарів, і пацієнтів, перебоїв із постачанням поки вдалося уникнути.
Натомість перед іншою проблемою - нестачею персоналу - лікарня безсила.
Працюють по дві медсестри на посту. Це дуже стомлює. Обсяг роботи дуже великий. Це зовсім інші хворі, вони потребують зовсім іншої уваги.
І, власне, саме надання медичної допомоги є складним. Багато маніпуляцій,
треба поміряти сатурацію, перевірити рівень кисню, тиск кисню - це стомлює.
Крім того, паперова робота. Дехто боїться. А ви знаєте, закон забороняє змусити, тому що це є зміна істотних умов праці,
це має бути тільки за згодою медперсоналу. Чесно сказати, боюся, ми всі боїмося,
але ми знали, на що ідемо, з ким працюємо. Тобто ворога знаємо в обличчя. Тільки б він не мінявся.
Лікарі розповідають, що перебіг хвороби останнім часом змінився.
Хворіє більше молодих людей, загалом - довше і важче.
Часто спостерігають кровохаркання, а ураження зазнають не тільки легені, але й інші органи та системи -
серцево-судинна, сечовидільна, периферична нервова.
Нерідко на восьмий-десятий день, коли мало б починатися одужання, пацієнтам навпаки стає гірше.
Задишка була сильна і температура, ламало. Починалося, як звичайний грип.
Ломота в кістках, руки-ноги крутило, потім піднялася температура, почалася задишка.
Я лікувався сім днів амбулаторно, потім загальний стан погіршився і потрапив сюди.
По суті, я хворію вже 11-й день. Дуже великий був наплив туристів під час зимових свят. Цілий січень було повно туристів, море туристів.
І все розповсюдилось по району, по області, ну, і пішло по Україні.
Я з Ворохти. Поступила сюди в поганому стані. Ніби ніде не ходила, вдома була.
В повітрі може щось. У Ворохті повно туристів було. І Буковель, і все... Я знаю?
На те, що саме спричинило спалах коронавірусу в Івано-Франківській області, лікарі та експерти досі не мають однозначної відповіді.
Серед причин називають масове повернення заробітчан, що приїхали додому на різдвяні свята,
які на Прикарпатті традиційно відзначають тривало та інтенсивно.
Ще одним фактором став масовий туризм у регіоні - відпочивати на гірськолижні курорти Карпат
цього року навіть під час січневого локдауну приїжджали тисячі людей з усіх куточків України та навіть із-за кордону.
Люди, які приїжджають туди відпочивати у зону туристичну, яремчанську зону - багато з них приїжджають інфіковані.
Вони можуть поселятися в Яремче, кататися на лижах в Буковелі. Тобто ночують в Яремче в готелі і катаються протягом дня в Буковелі.
Там можуть інфікувати тих, з ким перебувають в контакті, безпосередньо на підйомниках.
Ми повинні теж пам'ятати, що там великий тісний контакт відбувається перед підняттям на трасу гірськолижну,
і після цього вони успішно завершують своє катання і роз'їжджаються по домах.
І ось ці інфіковані люди теж пороз'їжджаються по своїх домівках, по різних регіонах і таким чином вірус може поширюватись і далі.
Червоною зоною Прикарпаття оголосили наприкінці лютого.
Проте відтоді найбільший в Україні гірськолижний курорт "Буковель", а також численні готелі і приватні садиби регіону
працювали ще понад два тижні - хоч і з певними обмеженнями.
На карантин "Буковель" закрили лише 13-го березня, а біля села Поляниця, де розташований курорт, облаштували блок-пости.
За словами головного санлікаря області Руслана Савчука, потрапити в Поляницю нині можуть лише місцеві жителі або ті, хто там працює.
Насправді ж, як з'ясувала знімальна група DW, контроль на блок-постах - символічний.
Раніше ми записували, якщо є температура - записували дані, звідки та куди їде, і просили звернутися до сімейного лікаря.
Зараз такої температури не спостерігається.
- DW: Але навіть якщо була б, не завернули б людину?
- Не завертаємо. Ми не маємо такого права - завернути. Ми маємо право тільки їм порекомендувати звернутися до сімейного лікаря.
Це все, що ми можемо їм сказати.
Не хоче показувати. - Немає температури взагалі? - Просто дуже холодно і градусник замерз, напевно.
Нині туристів у селі Поляниця дійсно майже немає.
Адже, хоча готелі і садиби на курортах працюють, діє заборона на роботу підйомників -
тож покататися на лижах у Буковелі наразі не вдасться.
Щоправда, представники курорту вважають такі обмеження несправедливими.
Я думаю, варто спитати тих людей, які сьогодні залишилася без роботи.
Мова зараз не про туристичний комплекс "Буковель", а про всю територію, яка навколо нього.
Тому що дійсно Поляниця, Микуличин, Яремче, Татарів та інші населені пункти, які навколо Буковелю -
туристичний комплекс для них великий магніт, який притягує тисячі людей.
І зараз всі ці місцеві люди, які мають малий або середній бізнес, терплять дуже великі збитки.
Наразі над цією справою працюють наші юристи.
Згідно зі всіма законами, нормами, постановами Буковель мав і має право працювати.
Щодо того, яке рішення ухвалила обласна державна адміністрація, тут ми вбачаємо заполітизовані дії.
Чи будуть пом'якшені карантинні обмеження в Івано-Франківській області, має стати відомо 27-го березня.
Останнім часом у регіоні позначилась тенденція до зниження захворюваності -
з майже 900 випадків на день наприкінці лютого до менше 250 останніми днями.
Утім, лікарі Яремчанської лікарні переконані: до подолання спалаху - ще далеко.
Тож резервні ліжка для ковідних пацієнтів у коридорах прибирати поки не планують.